week the official r number was between
0.8
and 1. this week it is between 0.7
and 1.1 in other words the r has gone
down
and it's gone up things are according to
this simultaneously getting worse
and getting better if this sounds a bit
unclear well that's because the outbreak
itself is not very clear right now
if you look at regional growth rates
here you see that in some areas
mainly in the north the virus may
actually be growing that's what these
dots up here mean whereas in other areas
like london
it's definitely shrinking overall
lockdown is probably working
because a decrease in london has a
bigger effect on a decrease in the rest
of the country
but looking at this it's not at all
clear that lockdown is stopping the
virus in its tracks
which is why you get the r going up and
down
you can see this mixed picture reflected
here in the latest survey data from the
office for national statistics
this is probably our most reliable
estimate of the state of the outbreak
and look if you see up here since the
start of lockdown infections have come
down
but they're not falling very fast and
crucially they're still
right up here they're still at a high
level
you can see the same thing as well with
hospital emissions they are falling
here which is encouraging and they
probably will fall further because
they're going down in london
but without outside intervention it's
hard to see how they're going to go from
here
all the way down to here where they were
in august very quickly
of course we do have outside
intervention we have the vaccine
and rollout is going well so we should
expect to see the results of that
in this kind of data in the next few
weeks
but in a way what this data and all of
the the data we've seen today
shows is just how reliable we are on the
vaccine
otherwise if you think about it we've
got a virus that's more transmissible
than march
but the rules are less strict than march
and the movement data that's we've got
here
this shows that people are moving about
right down here they're moving about
more than they were
back in march this is as a measure of
social activity
and that's what spread the virus when
you look at this
and all the other data you come to one
conclusion
we need that vaccine and we need
supplies of it to come through
fast